[Musique]
l'accès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
il faut que je vous raconte quelque
chose il ne s'agit pas d'une fiction
mais d'une histoire véritable est d'un
intérêt capital
cette histoire fut recueilli par solon
qu'il entendit sortir de la bouche de
prêtres qui eux mêmes la tenait de la
déesse égyptienne net
ensuite christian l'ancien la raconte à
son fils qui est le neveu l'atlantide
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peut-être qu'il est énoncé par platon ce
mythe est une allégorie qui a valeur de
modèle pour la société grecque selon la
légende l'atlantide est une île située
quelque part dans l'océan est occupé par
une civilisation glorieuses et puissante
les atlantes contrôler un vaste
territoire en méditerranée et lorsqu'ils
tentent de se mettre les grecs une
explosion cataclysmique a lieu lors il
disparaît à jamais en somme de la
science fiction à la mode antique
si on devait proposer lille réelles
constituées cette fable il faut avouer
que santorin fait plutôt la sphère en
plein centre de la mer egée terra plus
connu sous le nom de santorin et l'une
des îles les plus touristiques des
cyclades vers 1600 avant notre ère un
séisme suivi d'une éruption volcanique
ont presque rayés de la carte cette île
nommée à l'époque strong il est en grec
la ronde ce qui devait parfaitement
décrire sa forme originelle santorin
connaît toujours une forte activité
volcanique et sa forme actuelle n'est
que le résultat de ces éruptions
successives l'immense baie où transitent
de bien trop large paquebot de croisière
n'est autre que la caldeira c'est à dire
l'ancienne chambre magmatique
l'éruption qui détruisit lille vers 1600
avant notre ère a fait effondrer
laquelle des rats dans la mer est aussi
propulsé 50 kilomètres cubes de magma
dans l'atmosphère
l'explosion a aussi eu des répercussions
sur toute la mer egée puisqu'on estime
qu'elle a provoqués a co
tsunami qui a suivi la destruction n'est
pas les crétois dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode précédent
une telle catastrophe a dû être l'objet
de récit fantastique durant des
générations jusqu'à arriver aux oreilles
de plateau milan de récit oral de la
catastrophe ont transformé santorin en
mythe milan de bouche à oreille et
santorin fini dans l'atlantique la fin
ty à santorin donc après tout
l'occupation de l'île est ancienne et
les descriptions d'une cité prospère et
raffiné peuvent faire penser à un site
du sud de son torrent akrotiri
l'explosion volcanique n'a pas seulement
dévasté la région il y a trois mille six
cent ans mais elle a aussi conservé sous
les cendres un village de l'âge du
bronze akrotiri et le pompéi de la
préhistoire aux seuls sites européens de
cette époque a livré à la fois des
maisons à étage de très nombreux objets
du quotidien et des fresques polychrome
grâce aux analyses biologiques des
différentes couches de cendres qui ont
enseveli la cité on peut restituer
toutes les phases de la catastrophe
il faut d'abord expliquer une chose
c'est que l'éruption n'a pas fait de
victime humaine
aucun corps n'a été retrouvé lors des
fouilles quand on en parle à que les
habitants où le temps de s'enfuir
hypothèse confirmée par le géologue
puisque un tremblement de terre s'est
produit quelques temps avant l'explosion
de l'île et a décidé la population à la
quitter
visitez ce site c'est d'abord être
frappé par l'immensité des runes fouillé
deux hectares à l'heure actuelle ou été
mise au jour par les archéologues
ensuite ce sont les détails
architecturaux qui témoigne du soin
apporté à la construction de ce village
préhistorique les vestiges des murs
atteignent parfois plusieurs mètres de
hauteur permettant de comprendre les
méthodes utilisées les maisons très
haute on un système de colombages pour
renforcer la structure et la protéger
des secousses sismiques pour passer d'un
étage à l'autre
il y avait des escaliers hambourg est
parfois en pierre bien loin de l'image
que l'on se fait d'un village de
pêcheurs de presque 4000 ans des
archéologues imagine d'habitude des
échelles ou pas des tâches du tout pour
ces périodes
au-delà de ces détails de construction
il faut imaginer que toutes les maisons
étaient peintes décorée de fresques
murales représentant les activités
commerciales et agricoles de l'île des
pêcheurs des fleurs des fruits des
cueilleuses de safran des antilopes et
même des singes double animaux exotiques
ramené de voyages lointains pour les
scientifiques le réalisme de certaines
scènes et d'un apport historique
considérable
santorin devait être en grand le niveau
de confort des maisons neil assez
prospère grâce aux activités de pêche
d'agriculture d'élevage et de kaunas
maritime et cette abondance se lit sur
les murs aux oiseaux dauphin grappes de
raisin chèvres sauvages roseaux crocus
lierre et qui a brillé une ville qui ne
manquaient de rien qui vivait
paisiblement jusqu'à la catastrophe
par contre le développement culturel et
économique de l'île cycladique ne
correspond pas à la puissance supposée
de l'atlantide sentent aura été prospère
oui mais n'avait pas de flotte militaire
et n'était pas autre chose qu'un joli
port perdu en pleine mer egée la crête
j'aurais mieux ce rôle de plateforme
commerciale puisque elle possédait une
puissance navale capable de contrôler
une partie du bassin oriental
méditerranéen mais la crête n'a jamais
été engloutis même si l'éruption du
volcan de santorin et a laissé des
traces de sang volcanique doit être et
qui a conservé la ville
on sait que le récit de cet épisode
incroyable s'est transmis de façon orale
pendant des siècles jusqu'à tomber dans
le registre des mythes et à brouiller la
mémoire des lieux et des époques
c'est peut-être cette réalité historique
qui a inspiré à plat tout le mythe de
l'atlantide
mais les influences du mythe sont
toujours pluriel il ne faut pas oublier
d'où écrit plates ou l'infanticide
c'est une mise en garde
c'est ce que risquent de devenir athènes
si elle se laisse emporter par son
orgueil camper réaliste platon craint
qu'athènes ne se détourne de ses
traditions tourné vers la terre le
travail agricole pour céder à l'appel du
large et du commerce maritime
comme toute fable la morale y est
explicite
la chute sera terrible
[Musique]